[موسيقى]
طب توم و طابته اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى
بانوراما وهذه عناوينها
الاحتجاجات في الاردن هل سببها ارتفاعه
اسعار المحروقات فقط ام ان وراءها اطرافا
واهدافا اخرى
لاستئذان من امريكا قبل توجيه ضربه لايران
والعلاقه مع واشنطن تحتاج لاعاده تاكيد
ماذا تعني تصريحاته نتنياهو للعربيه
الانجليزيه
في استفتاء من صناعه الالماسك مستخدم
وتويتر يرفضون استمرار هو رئيسا للمنصه
العملاق فهل سيصدق ويتنحى ام انها واحده
من فوازير ومناوراتي
حياكم الله جهود السلطات الاردنيه في
مواجهه التطورات الامنيه المتعلقه بحادثه
مقتل العقيد عبد الرزاق الدلابيح منذ ايام
في محافظه معان جنوب البلاد مستمره حيث
اكد من العام الاردني ان قوه امنيه خاصه
نفذت مداهمه لخليه ارهابيه في منطقه
الحسينيه في معان بعد انقادت التحقيقات
بحصر الاشتباه بمجموعه من الاشقاء من حمله
من حمله الفكر التكفيري وقال لمن العام في
بيان له ان القوه الامنيه الخاصه حصلت
مكان المجتبهم قام احدهم وفور بدء
المداعبه باطلاقه عيارات ناريه مكثفه ما
اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه من ضباط وافراد القوه
واصابه اخرين ومقتل الارهابي مطلق الناره
كما افضت المداهمه لالقاء القبض على تسعه
الاخرين مشتبهم منهم اربعه اشقاء للارهابي
المقتول وثلاثه من ابناء احدهم ومعه شخصان
اخران كان برفقتهم وض- ضبط بحوزتهم مجموعه
من الاسلحه الناريه وكميه كبيره من
التخيره
له نفسه
[موسيقى]
ربنا ربنا
اعلنا من البدايه بان مع الاردن مع الوطن
مع الاجهزه الامنيه والزننا بيان امبارح
اعطينا الاجهزه الامنيه المده الكافيه من
اجل انه اظهار الحق واظهار القتله القاتل
بين
اليوم ليس ك- البارحه اطلب الجميع
المواطنين الابتعاد عن كل الاماكن التي
تضم اعمال عنف فصل الاحتجاجات السلميه
المسموحه والتعبير السلمي عن اعمال العلم
واجباته لما يحفظ الامن والسلم المجتمعي
وان يعيد الحياه مستقره لابناء هذا الوطن
ينضم الينا من عمان محمود الخرابشه وزير
الدوله للشؤون القانونيه سابق ومن عمان
ايضا عمر الرداد الخبير الامني اهلا بكما
يعني ليبدا مع وزير الدوله للشؤون
القانونيه سابق الاستاذ محمود الخرابشه
بدايه هذه المطالب هل هي بالفعل يعني
احتجاجات مطلبيه ناجمه عن ارتفاع اسعار
المحروقات ام ان وراءها ما وراءها وهو عمل
مدبر
شكرا يا اخي لا الحقيقه هي بدات احتجاجات
سلميه وكما هو معلوم ان الاحتجاجات
السلميه
مصانع بموجب الدستور وبالتالي بدات هذه
الاحتجاجات من المواطنين الذين يعتقدون
انهم قد تضرروا جراء رفع الاسعار لكن الذي
حصل ان فئه من الظلاميين والذين يصطادون
في المياه العكره قد استغلوا هذه الفرصه
التي يعبر بها المواطنين الاردنيين
والسلميا عن مطالبهم وعرفهم بزياده
الاسعار وتمكنوا من خلال هذا الاستغلال ان
يقوموا بالاعتداء واطلاق النار على مجموعه
على رجال الامن مما ادى الى استشهاد
العميد الدلابيح رحمه الله وعلى اثر ذلك
طبعا قامت الاجهزه الامنيه والامن العام
بحصر
البحث والتحري اما كان قد اطلق النار مما
ادى الى استشهاد العميد الدلابيح وتمكنوا
من حصر هذه الفئه التي تم القوه لمداهمتها
لكن هذه الفئه قامت باطلاق النار باتجاه
مجموعه قوه الامن العام مما ادى الى
استشهاد ثلاثه من من ثلاثه من هذه
المجموعه منهم ضابطان ضابط صب واصابه خمسه
من الاخرين لكن نحن نقول اننا مع كل مطالب
السلميه ومع حق التعبير وما حق الدفاع
السلمي ايضا عن وجهات النظر شريطه الا
يؤدي ذلك الى العنف وان لا يصل الى
الاعتداء على الارواح والممتلكات لكن الذي
حصل كما قلت ان هذه الفئه الظلاميه قد
حاولت استغلال هذه الظروف ومن خلال هذا
الاستغلال البشع تمكنت ان تطلق النار على
رجال الامن العام مما ادى الى ما ادى عليه
مما ادى الى ما ادى اليه ونحن نقول رحمهم
الله ونتمنى للمصابين ان شاء الله الشفاء
العاجل الى السيد عمر الرداد الخبير
الامني هذه التظاهرات وهذه الاحتجاجات هل
هي كانت
خصبه او مفتوحه الى هذه الدرجه لكي يتسلى
اليها اصحاب هذا الفكر همم ام ان هم جزء
من هذه الاحتجاجات ولهم مارب اخرى غير ما
هي قائمه في الشارع
مساء الخير لك
ولضيفك الكريم
اعتقد اعتقد بالفعل همم
كما تفضل استاذ الخراب شيء بدات باحداث
بمطالب جماهيريه
مرتبطه بقطاع محدد وهو قطاع سائقي
الشاحنات توسعت همم ما اريد ان اقول
ايجابي على تساؤلك الذي تفضلت به لانه هذا
الخلايا الارهابيه النائمه وهذا الفكر همم
التكبير المتطرف همم يجد همم
حاضنه ومناسبه وتوقيت مناسب وسياقات عامه
همم يستثمر من خلال اهلها هذه الاحداث
خاصه وان الاعتصامات والحركات اللي تمت في
مناطق منطقه معان همم ذهبت الى الشارع
وهمم
تصرفت وف للقانون في البدايه لكنها سرعان
ما تطورت بمنع الراغبين بعدم المشاركه
بالاعتصاب والذاهبين وتم ايقاف الشاحنات
واصبحت همم هناك فئه تمارس القانون خارجي
اطار القانون المكلف في القيام به
وبتنفيذه الامن العام والاجهزه المختلفه
همم الفئه التكفيريه هذه اللي موجوده في
المنطقه وحسب حتى اعترافاتها الاوليه التي
اصدرها واعلنها الامن العام اليوم همم
انهم همم
قاموا باغلاق الشارع العام في منطقه
الحسينيه وكانوا يدركوا ان قوه امنيه
ستاتي لفتح الشارع وهو ما ادى لاطلاق
النار عبر كميل محدد للقوه الامنيه
القادمه التي ذهب ضحيتها الشهيد العقيده
طيب نعم يعني هنا دعني اسالك هل هذه همم
هي همم بحاجه اليوم نحن لمراجعه امنيه
الوضع لمراجعه همم حتى التشريعيه لحقوق
همم المحتاجين او المتظاهرين ام همم لعمل
الجهاز الامني وكيفيه التصرف حياله ذلك
الامر هل هو عمل استخباراتنا قسمه
لا لا اعتقد ان العمل الاستخبارات ناقص
دليل ان التدخل الامني التدخل الامني الذي
تم بهذه الصيغه ومواجهه هذه الخليه
المتطرفه بهذه المنطقه تحديدا يجب ان
نتذكر ان همم اسبوعين كاملين قبل ذلك همم
كان يتم فيها قطع الطريق وكان يتم التعامل
همم بكل قانوني وبيكون لطف مع المتظاهرين
وكانت هناك محاوله
لاقناعهم بالتوقف عن عن اغلاق الشارع ولم
تحدث ايه اصابات او اي احتكاكات بين الامن
العام
والمتظاهرين في محافظه معان تحديدا على
الطريق الصحراوي لكن الاحتكاك هذا
الاحتكاك والاطلاق النار حدث في منطقه
الحسينيه تابعه اداريه لمحافظه معان بعد
ان تدخل المتطرفون واعتقد اليوم ان 10
ايام او اكثر السبوع الى اسبوعين همم
بوجود الاعتصامات دون تدخل امني طيب
باستخدام القوه ضد المتظاهرين يؤكد على
سلامه الاجراءات الامنيه وانها هذه
الاجراءات لم تكن لتكون الا حينما تدخل
المتطرفون والارهابيون بهذه الصيغه التي
استهدف فيها الامن العام وهم يخيطوا لذلك
واضح جدا كانت تخطيطا مقصودا ومبيتا
الاستثمار هذا الحدث بهذا الاسم
الى سيد محمود الخرابشه اليوم حينما نتحدث
عن انه همم هذه البيئه هل كانت مهياه
لدخول هكذا عناصر من انه همم مشاهدنا كما
تحدث انت اضراب السائقين وقبلها حتى
المدرسين لم تكن هناك حاله عنف بهذه
بعمليات اطلاق النار ولكن استغلالها هل هو
ايضا انعكاس لبيئه الاسلام السياسي في
الاردن وربما حتى تطرفها
يعني الحقيقه اخي انت تعلم ان الاردن قد
عانى من الارهاب مرارا وتكرارا وهنالك
محاولات يائس كثيره كانت قد تمت سابقا
ابتداءا من عمليه الفنادق الى عمليه الكرك
الى عمليه اربد الى عمليه الركبان الى
عمليه السلط وغيرها من العمليات لكن
الاردن لديه من الخبره ما يكفي لكي يتعامل
مع هذه التنظيمات ولكي يكبح جماحها في
الوقت المناسب هذه التنظيمات مع الاحترام
حضرتك اشرت الى انه اعاده اعاده تشريعيه
او صيغه تشريعيه لا الحقيقه نحن لدينا
الدستور الاردني يكفى الحريه الراي
والتعبير ويكفل ايضا لكل مواطن ان يكون
همم مخاطبه السلطات العامه فيما ينوب من
امور خاصه عامه ويكفل حق الاجتماعي لكن
الذي حصل ان هذه الخليه النائمه او هذه
الفئه النائمه استغلت هذه الظروف وانت
تعلم ان الاردن في موجه الربيع العربي هو
الدوله العربيه الوحيده الذي يتعامل
بسياسه الامن ناعم والتي لم تؤدي بالنتيجه
الى اراقه اي قطره الدم سواء كان من
المواطنين او من رجال الامن والقوات
المسلحه وخرج منها سالما معافا الاردن
حقيقه يتعامل مع مواطنين من منطلق ان
لدينا ديمقراطيه ولدين حريه راي وحريه
تعبير والمواطن يستطيع ان يعبر عن رايه
بحريه طالما ان الدستور قد كفيل هذه
الحريه شريطه ان تكون هذه الممارسه وهذا
التعبير بموجب احكام الدستور والقانون
بمعنى الا يخرج عن الاطر التي تعتدي على
الاموال والممتلكات وتؤدي بالتالي الى
الخروج على القانون لكن صحيح هنالك خلايا
نائمه لكن هذا ينبه الدوله بين كل فتره
واخرى واجهتها الى ان تقوم بدورها وواجبها
بمتابعه هذه الخلايا القبض عليها وشوكه
لكي تطالها
عن يعني الخلايا النائمه همم بعد قليل
ولكن انا بودي انا اسال اليوم هنا القبائل
همم ما هو دورها في هكذا باقه في اليوم
بالتاكيد عم ال- ال- ال- ال- الاردن مجتمع
عشائري
صحيح
يعني الاردنيه في كل الموادع عبرت عن
رفضها واستنكارها لايه محاوله تستهدف
النيل من امن الوطن واستقراره وعبرت ايضا
ببيانات وباجتماعات وبمخاطبات رسميه عن
رفضها الكامل لاي مواجهه مع رجال الامن
والقوات المسلحه باعتبار ان هؤلاء يسهرون
ويؤمنون الراحه والامن والامان للمواطنين
وبالتالي جميع ابناء الوطن الاردني بكل
اطياف في المخيم في القريه في المدينه اين
ما كانوا في الارياف يقفون صفا واحدا خلف
قيادتهم الهاشميه دائمين ومشاندين لقواتهم
المسلحه واجهزتهم الامير دفاعا عن الاردن
وامن الاردن واستقراره وانت تعلم انه كما
قلت ان هنالك محاولات يائس قد تمت سابقا
لكن تمكن الاردن من حصلها
واريد ان يذكر حظرتك انه يد الاجهزه
الامنيه كطاله الكربولي وهو في العراق
وتمكنك من سوقه وكذلك
كل العشاير الاردنيه
الامني عنه يعني ليس هناك ضرر من ان تراجع
الاجهزه الامنيه حتى عملها او حتى
تحرياتها الفكر المتشدد ليس جامدا لهم
طرقهم حتى انتشار بين فئه معينه مختلفه هل
من المفترض ان الاجهزه الامنيه ايضا تراقب
او تجدد حتى قوائمها ومن هو موجود على هذه
القوائم
نعم اعتقد همم الاجهزه الامنيه تتابع
وبشكل همم
بمختلف همم سواء المخابرات العامه او
الامن العام وحتى الاستخبارات العسكريه
وهناك همم تنسيق وتكامل همم مشترك بين هذه
الاجهزه بتجديد القوائم وتغيير هذه
القوائم وحياه تدرك ايضا همم تغير
الاساليب وتنوح على هذه الجماعات اذ انه
عملها ليس مقصورا همم فقط على مناطق تحدث
فيها احداث شغب او احتجاجات وتنفذ من
خلالها
الكثير من الاساليب التي تمارس النجوم
وتتغير الانواعات تحديدا ما اريد ان اتحدث
عنه
باختصار اكمل فكره
نعم نعم ايه هناك كما قلت اساليب متعدده
اليوم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هي من ابرز
المحددات وهناك جيوش الكترونيه لدى
الاسلام السياسي ولا ده المتطرفين ايضا
والارهابيين يدخلون من خلالها ويحاولون بث
الاشاعات لتغيير قناعات الناس ربما
المبالغه
بما يحدث وربما يقوم بعضهم بالتغطيه
والتغيير في العمل الارهابي دون ادانته
وهذا مشهود له بالاردن بمواقف ومواقع
متعدده شكرا
الموصول يا سيد محمود الخربشه وزير الدوله
لشؤون القانونيه السابقه شكرا جزيلا
بانوراما مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
الاستئذان من امريكا قبل توجيهي ضربه
لايران والعلاقه مع واشنطن تحتاج لاعاده
تاكيد ماذا تعني تصريحات نتنياهو للعربيات
الانجليزيه